[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité
un test grandeur nature pour lutter
contre les incendies dans les Vosges des
Canadairs essayer à l'écopage sur un lac
local des images impressionnantes de
Vosges télévision à découvrir dans
quelques instants le rêve d'un jeune
soldat contre la maladie et la rédaction
de Canal 32 nous racontera la belle
histoire de Maxence un enfant malade de
7 ans qui a pu réaliser son rêve se
glisser dans la peau d'un militaire le
temps d'une journée
et puis en fin de journal nous suivrons
le travail de scientifique chargé de
protéger la faune marine en Martinique
les eaux de l'île abritent un sanctuaire
pour la préservation des mammifères et
de leurs habitats de belles images de
nos partenaires sur place de via ATV
voilà l'été approche direction les
Vosges c'est sur le lac de Gérardmer que
viennent d'être effectué des tests
grandeurs nature des copages objectifs
s'adapter à la multiplication des feux
de forêts dans la zone et trouver ainsi
de nouvelles sources d'approvisionnement
pour éteindre les incendies les
précisions d'Aurélie Colombelles pour
voter les visions
survol de l'avion rouge et jaune des
pompiers au-dessus de Gérardmer images
inédite test grandeur nature découpage
de Canadair le lac de montagne pourrait
intégrer le dispositif anti-incendie du
Grand Est sur ce test ici parce que les
proximités et surtout l'enseignement des
feux de forêts de l'été dernier nous ont
montré que ce serait bien qu'on puisse
avoir cette possibilité cette capacité
là ici aujourd'hui le lac de Gérardmer
et primordial en termes de d'appui
opérationnel au troupeau sol parce que
dans le sud-est du département et
surtout de la zone de défense c'est le
seul point des copages qui pourrait être
qualifié les violences incendies de
l'été dernier 79 départs de feu en une
semaine 150 hectares parti en fumée les
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
oblige à revoir les stratégies
d'intervention des secours des
hélicoptères bombardiers d'eau
interviennent déjà en cas de nécessité
des dashs des avions rechargeables au
sol peuvent s'envoler du Pélican Drôme
de Mirecourt ses moyens pourraient être
rejoints par des Canad parvenu de Nîmes
ou de pays frontaliers si les tests sont
concluants la sécurité civile en France
dispose de 12 canadairs et de sidaches
qui sont basés à la base de sécurité
civile de Nîmes garons le dispositif
opérationnel estival va entraîner
certainement en fonction des risques de
sensibilité au feu un prépositionnement
de ses moyens et donc avec la
disposition du Pélican Drôme d'Épinal
Mirecourt
l'intérêt de qualifier le lac de
Gérardmer à toute son importance sur un
lac touristique comme celui de la Perle
des Vosges les contraintes sont
nombreuses les flots et les chemins ont
dû être évacués mais Gérardmer et
stratégiquement bien situé dispositif de
sécurité renforcé aujourd'hui qu'il
faudra encore une fois si c'était ses
concluant validé au final et mettre tout
un plan en œuvre l'avion a besoin de
deux kilomètres l'étendue ne fait qu'un
kilomètre 900 avec la ville à proximité
immédiate
[Musique]
la densité de population et la forme
encaissée de la vallée ne permettrait
pas un usage en toute sécurité
des sourires et une belle histoire de
Maxence un enfant de 7 ans militaire le
temps d'une journée atteint d'une
maladie grave ce petit garçon a pu
accomplir son souhait le plus cher
côtoyé des soldats et partager leur
quotidien vêtu d'un treillis et le
visage bariolé Maxence a vécu une
journée qu'il n'est pas prêt d'oublier
un reportage de la rédaction de Canal 32
regarde
Maxence n'a que 7 ans mais pas forcément
la vie devant lui atteint d'une maladie
génétique auto-immune dans l'attente
d'une greffe de moelle osseuse
compatible grâce à ses parents et à
l'association petit prince il a pu
réaliser son rêve vivre le quotidien
d'un soldat de l'armée de terre durant
une journée
mais bon j'ai pas lâché pour Maxence ça
c'est clair
c'est
de s'oublier parce que sa maladie peut
mourir donc je veux qu'il kiffe sa vie
les véhicules jouer au jeu des vidéos un
jeu de simulation c'est ça
durant cette journée Maxence a partagé
le quotidien des militaire
notamment un tour un char d'assaut des
exercices de simulation d'entraînement
un foot durant la pause et un goûter
dans l'un des engins du génie ou bien
encore la détection de métaux
c'est un objet c'est une pièce
en raison de la covid l'organisation de
cette parenthèse dans le quotidien du
suivi de la maladie a nécessité trois
ans de patience une journée magique pour
l'enfant une première au sein du 5e
régiment de dragon m'attendez pas à
cette union en fait autour de lui
derrière le militaire il y a peut-être
un père de famille à une mère de famille
je pense que voir Maxence comme ça aussi
ça a fait quelque chose en eux je suis
sûr que ça va réveiller en lui une
énergie c'est une énergie qui nous
permet aussi d'avancer moi pour nous
c'est une grande première et on aimerait
vraiment que ça se reproduise le sourire
d'un enfant n'a pas de prix
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup de parents nous disent et bien
grâce à vous on n'a jamais vu notre
enfant rire comme ça depuis si longtemps
il a recommencé à prendre ses
traitements enfin ça a un impact bien
plus puissant que ce que l'on peut
imaginer depuis 37 ans Petit Prince a
réalisé près de 9000 rêves d'enfants
elle fermait les unes après les autres
il y a 50 ans les mines de Saint-Étienne
ont marqué durablement l'histoire de la
ville et près d'un demi-siècle plus tard
les derniers mineurs se souviennent de
leur travail dans des conditions pour le
moins compliqué la rédaction de TL7 dans
la Loire a recueilli notamment le
témoignage de Pierre Perronet un ancien
picker qui a passé 25 ans au contact du
charbon aujourd'hui âgé de 90 ans il
livre ses souvenirs assez inertie il y a
regardé
dans ce classeur pierre Perronet garde
précieusement une partie de ces trésors
des photos tous reliées au charbon et à
sa carrière de mineur
mon père c'était pas simple
pour élever mon famille pierre Perronet
était la troisième génération de mineurs
de sa famille à sa première descente il
la fera à 19 ans et il sera piqueur
pendant 25 ans on puisse Sanya à
l'époque rare était les mineurs qui
racontait ce qu'il se passait au fond
des mines mais aujourd'hui Pierre
Perronet parle librement de l'amitié
incomparable entre mineurs la chaleur
qu'il est poussait à se déshabiller pour
travailler mais aussi les moments de
stress et parfois d'éroïsme comme cette
fois où il a sorti un ami après un
éboulement
que je rentre dans le trou alors
j'aimerais enlever mes deux bras lui il
a fermé mes deux poignets j'ai pas eu
besoin de tenir je dis franchement parce
que lui ça permet dur et les gars
derrière mon tirer lui il pleurait comme
un
l'après-midi même il est venu à la
maison pour me remercier et m'a dit je
redescendrai plus en ami et il est plus
redescendu et l'aventure des mines s'est
arrêtée il y a 50 ans un anniversaire
qui est passé inaperçu pour Pierre
Perronet Lamine le charbon on représenté
toute sa carrière il en a même fait son
art aujourd'hui il souhaite transmettre
son histoire pour que le passé minier
reste dans les mémoires
des informations
usage des réseaux sociaux libertés
d'expression voilà certainement des
thématiques difficiles à appréhender
pour les jeunes générations c'est pour
les aider à y voir un peu plus clair que
les journées d'éducation aux médias et à
l'information sont organisées en milieu
scolaire dans l'Oise c'est une
cinquantaine de lycéens qui a pu
s'immerger dans l'univers des médias
grâce à l'intervention de professionnels
parmi eux la caméra de Jérôme Aubron
journaliste pour Réo TV notre partenaire
la chaîne de la Voix du Nord et du
Courrier Picard
on utilise un casque pourquoi parce que
ça va nous isoler du bruit extérieur on
va pouvoir se concentrer sur ce sur ce
concave entrer dans la peau d'un
journaliste de radio voilà un exercice
qui sort de l'ordinaire pour ses lycéens
première étape avant immersion ce
familiariser avec l'équipement c'est là
je te parle pas quelque chose vas-y
regarde tu vas tu vas t'entendre parler
des interviews des prises de son une
découverte pour Anaïs qui doit présenter
la filière menuiserie de son
établissement le temps d'un reportage
[Musique]
c'est une nouvelle expérience
expérience menée par l'arcome auprès
d'une cinquantaine d'élèves de la
troisième au bac pro au travers des
ateliers l'Autorité de régulation du
paysage audiovisuel en tant sensibiliser
les plus jeunes à l'usage des médias et
des informations qu'il véhiculent il
faut aussi qu'ils aient conscience que
tout ne peut pas être dit sans impunité
il y a des lois respecter des règlements
et donc l'arcome est là également pour
protéger les publics pour assurer un
cadre législatif où tout le monde peut
s'exprimer en toute connaissance de
cause bonjour bonjour à tous vous êtes
sur Clem radio il est 11h derrière son
micro Lana est chargé d'animer
l'émission de la web radio du lycée pour
elle s'éduquer aux médias c'est aussi
rassuré une génération souvent noyée
sous les informations
c'est génial parce que c'est vrai que
plus les générations avancent et plus
elles sont scotché à leur téléphone donc
je pense le fait d'encadrer tout ce
qu'ils peuvent voir et la quantité de ce
qu'ils peuvent visionner c'est important
selon un rapport de l'Institut Reuters
en 2022 l'actualité en ligne devant
c'est la télévision comme source
d'informations hebdomadaire chez les
Français
sans transition dans ce journal dites
adieu au coton-tige pour prendre soin de
vos oreilles et de l'environnement
passer la laisse cuette ce cure oreille
écologique est fabriqué en Bretagne une
base en bois et une pelle en inox pour
nettoyer son oreille le principe est
simple et séduit de plus en plus de
personnes reportages dans l'usine où est
fabriqué l'escurette de Natacha Astor
pour TVR
dans cette tournerie à la
chapelle-bexique un objet étonnant et
fabriqué voici le cure oreille made in
France nommé l'escurette ici le bois de
charme est raboté pour former les
manches et les capuchons s'ensuivent la
gravure et la teinte des Cure oreilles
depuis 4 ans on en a fabriqué 200000
c'est du bois qui vient de l'est de la
France même au niveau de la teinte on
utilise des Saintes à l'eau et des une
huile naturelle c'est après la loi
contre le plastique à usage unique mis
en place en 2020 que Briac et Sylvie
déposent leurs marques quatre ans plus
tard l'entreprise familiale se porte
très bien les associés assemblent l'inox
médical fabriqué en Normandie l'objet
est vendu dans les magasins bio vrac
zéro déchet sur les salons dans les
pharmacies et depuis peu chez les
audioprothésistes aujourd'hui notre cure
oreille se trouve alors principalement
en France en Europe mais pas seulement
on a aussi des boutiques qui nous
vendent dans le monde entier ça
représente à ce jour environ 1600
différents points de vente en direct
l'entreprise de cinq salariés a reçu en
mai dernier la médaille de l'innovation
au concours Lépine en tant qu'
alternative éco-responsable au
coton-tige si on sait un peu d'histoire
remontons en moyenne on est entre 800 et
1400 au Moyen-Âge on a trois accessoires
d'hygiène on a un cure-dent prends soin
de sa bouche incuronble on fait
attention à ses mains et on a un cure
oreille qui à l'époque s'appelle une
escurette c'est d'ailleurs le nom qu'on
a repris pour notre fabrication on
trouvait ça plus sexy sur oreille
compter tout de même 10 euros pour ce
cure oreille un petit objet utilisable
toute une vie
[Musique]
voilà restons en Bretagne et la
sculpture du bois dans ce journal pour
découvrir l'activité étonnante de
Jean-Paul neveu se retraité fabrique des
stylos avec du bois récupéré au profit
d'une association une action qu'il mène
malgré une maladie qui le rend aveugle
une belle histoire que nous racontait
Nora le nôtre pour t'aimer ou la chaîne
du groupe télégramme
les gestes sont précis calculés pourtant
Jean-Paul neveu ne distingue que
quelques taches de lumière ce qui ne
l'empêche pas de transformer l’ancien
plancher de la mairie en stylo sans
avoir peur de se couper un doigt mais ça
peut m'arriver quand même une fois le
carrelet percé la pièce est mise dans le
tour à bois ou sa forme définitive sera
sculptée faire un seul stylo demandant
moyenne deux heures de travail Jean-Paul
qui a développé une passion pour la
menuiserie j'ai toujours été passionné
par le par le bois puis le hasard a fait
que je rencontre un jour quelqu'un qui
tournait du bois il m'avait invité chez
lui pour faire un essai et laisser c'est
montrer pas de pas si mal que ça je me
suis aperçu que c'était une activité qui
pouvait être à ma portée une fois
assemblée ce stylo rejoint les 50 autres
fabriqués à partir du plancher de
l'ancienne mairie les bénéfices de leur
vente seront reversés à l'association
quimperoise forceée dédiée au
financement de la recherche pour les
maladies génétiques une cause importante
pour Jean-Paul pour moi c'était un
besoin oui
presque vital pour moi c'est trop tard
moi
maritime elle est trop trop avancée mais
il faut penser des ondes générations à
venir quoi compter 15 euros pour vous
offrir un stylo ils seront vendus le 7
mai prochain au marché aux fleurs
d'Ergué-Gabéric
voilà des stylos des sacs des
accessoires mais aussi et surtout des
briquets iconiques depuis 150 ans est
Dupont et l'une des maisons les plus
emblématiques du luxe à la française et
c'est dans les Alpes que la manufacture
abrite la recette de son succès lucaruc
pour la rédaction de 8 Mont-Blanc vous
en dévoile quelques éléments avec ce
reportage regardez
quel est le point commun entre la reine
Élisabeth Picasso ou encore Marilyn
Monroe ils ont tous possédé à un moment
donné un objet fabriqué par la
manufacture ST Dupont et vous ne le
savez peut-être pas mais son usine se
trouve à Faverges au pied des montagnes
c'est ici que Simon Tissot Dupont le
fondateur de la marque qui installe en
1923 son usine et un siècle plus tard
elle est toujours là tout est fabriqué
dans cette manufacture spécialisée dans
la conception d'objets de luxe la maison
ST Dupont a d'ailleurs fait sa renommée
grâce à son iconique briquet à essence
l'objet aujourd'hui encore maintenant
malgré toutes les lois anti-fumeurs
restent le produit phare de la marque le
produit emblématique avec sa signature
visuelle tant par sa forme que par son
décor et par ses signatures aussi
sonores avec le bruit caractéristique
qu'il fait à l'ouverture par ailleurs
les autres produits fonctionnent très
très bien aussi notamment la
maroquinerie et les silos et le reste
des accessoires dans les différentes
allées de l'usine se mélangent les
hommes et les machines auparavant avec
les anciennes machines nous avons nous
avions besoin de deux mois et demi pour
sortir un premier corps de briquet
depuis les matières premières sur une
machine comme ça aujourd'hui en moins
d'une heure on a sorti notre première
pièce finie certaines étapes comme le
lacage la peinture ou encore le contrôle
qualité nécessite encore le geste manuel
pas moins de 15 savoir faire sont
maîtrisés par les différents ouvriers
ils ont notamment mis leur expertise en
commun pour fabriquer cette pièce de
haute création un briquet casino à
complications horlogères vendu 45000
euros pour ce genre de pièce d'art la
demande est croissante de quoi assurer à
la Manufacture un avenir tout feu tout
flamme
pour la sans transition cultiver ses
propres légumes pour développer une
cuisine de qualité et de proximité la
tendance se développe chez les
restaurateurs en Moselle c'est la voie
empruntée notamment par le chef d'une
enseigne réputée de la terre à
l'assiette les circuits courts et les
produits frais sont favorisés à ce sujet
de jean-milon et de Emma chez qui pour
Moselle télévision
bah là on est sur les premiers navets
bon ils seront prêts d'ici un bon mois
on a là-bas un peu plus loin sous le
voile on a planté les premiers
poids croctus c'est son laboratoire
assez Louvain ce terrain grandinnectar
où l'on retrouve aussi un étang et un
gîte va d'ici quelques jours alimenter
le restaurant de Thomas en produits
frais c'est ça qui me stimule en tant
que cuisinier par exemple j'ai envie de
récolter des petits navets j'ai envie de
de récolter des courgettes avec la fleur
j'ai envie de planter une laitue asperge
par exemple sur le jardin parce que tu
en trouves pas sur les marchés ben on
plante on essaye on fait des essais ça
marche ça marche pas bon au moins voilà
tu es libre et puis tu maîtrises
vraiment on va dire toute la chaîne pour
l'aider dans cette tâche et prendre soin
de ce lieu hors du temps Thomas embauché
deux personnes mais il a surtout dû
attendre trois longues années avant que
la terre soit prête à être cultivé la
terre on la travaille maintenant même si
on n'est pas forcément bénéficiaire en
fin d'année avec ça pour moi si tu
engranges dans le dans le calcul le gain
de qualité que tu as en produit
tu deviens bénéficiaire en fait malgré
ce facteur temps les prix sur la carte
du restaurant n'ont pas augmenté depuis
septembre le chef se fournit localement
en lait viande ou fruit malgré tout les
circuits courts restent contraignants en
termes d'organisation on n'est pas 100%
local 100% la merde on tend on essaye
une démarche en tout cas on essaie
d'être cohérent grâce à cette
philosophie le restaurant rayonne dans
toute la région
et même à l'international avec la
proximité du Luxembourg et de
l'Allemagne une juste récompense pour
une enseigne désireuse de proposer des
produits de qualité et locaux
voilà et puis bénéficier de produits
locaux c'est aussi possible en ville la
preuve en Gironde ou des sous-sols
servent d'abris à la production de
champignons on parle alors d'agriculture
urbaine sur place plusieurs centaines de
kilos de champignons bio sont extraits
chaque semaine les précisions avec ce
reportage d'Anaïs Escalona pour TV7 la
chaîne du groupe sud-ouest
une ferme urbaine dans un parking
souterrain abandonné cette nouvelle cave
agricole située en banlieue bordelaise
produit 400 kg de champignons bio par
semaine pour le fondateur ce végétal
présente un avantage certain il pousse
naturellement dans le noir il y a
certaines types de culture qui sont très
bien adaptés aux souterrains donc ça se
fait traditionnellement depuis des
centaines d'années c'est les champignons
et les endives qui ont pas de besoin de
lumière pour pousser et donc faut savoir
que les souterrains il y a très peu
d'amplitude thermique tout au long de
l'année c'est à dire que la température
va très peu varier au final à Florac est
ici à Lormont on compte à l'année 5
salariés cette ancienne aide à domicile
et habitante du quartier rempli entre 10
à 40 cagettes par jour un travail
qu'elle semble apprécier c'est pas
compliqué il y a juste accueillir et
récolter donc c'est très bien
donc on peut se mettre de la musique on
peut mettre la radio
on peut chanter on peut faire ce qu'on
veut donc
on peut faire ce qu'on veut des endives
bio et d'autres variétés de champignons
sont cultivés sur l'autre site basé à
Floirac en parallèle de ses activités
dans la région la société se développe
aussi à l'échelle nationale à Paris Lyon
ou encore Nantes
comment attirer les touristes en 2023 à
l'aube de la saison estivale et des
longs week-end du mois de mai les villes
et Office de Tourisme repensent les
pratiques commerciales au premier rang
desquelles la traditionnelle visite
touristique qui se partent aujourd'hui
de nouvelles formes vous allez le voir
exemple à Nîmes ou des visites sont
organisées en course à pied en afterwork
ou en pratiquant le yoga un reportage de
Livier Michel pourvu à Occitanie
au fond là-bas il y a quelque chose qui
est une source qu'on appelle la fontaine
et voilà le nom jardin de la fontaine à
première vue rien de spécial dans cette
visite des Jardins de la Fontaine mais à
y regarder de plus près certains détails
interpellent je suis inscrite par
rapport au cours de yoga et en fait je
trouvais ça intéressant de en même temps
faire une visite même si je suis
nymnoise yoga et tourisme tel est le
principe d'une des nouvelles formes de
visite lancée par l'Office de Tourisme
de Nîmes je me suis dit que c'était
important de faire le lien avec la
nature véritablement c'est-à-dire donner
quelques éclairages historiques mais
être plus dans la partie sensorielle et
l'appréciation de la nature et des
végétaux arrivé au pied de la tourmagne
c'est Camille qui prend le relais pour
une heure de relaxation une fois qu'on
est arrivé ici on va fermer nos yeux et
pour quelques instants je vais vous
proposer de diriger votre attention vers
tout ce qui nous entoure
je l'ai adapté très spécifiquement à la
visite guidée pour ramener les éléments
qui sont présents au sein des jardins à
savoir la terre le ciel l'eau aussi
cette dimension d'eau parce que chaque
posture de yoga a est lié à un élément
de la nature très reposant très agréable
super détendu relax j'ai envie de faire
la sieste course à pied After Work ou
balade littéraire 14 nouvelles formes de
visite sont programmées pour la saison
2023 leur coût de 5 à 12 euros
sans transition direction la Corse dans
ce journal les eaux de l'île de beauté
qui faisaient l'objet il y a quelques
jours d'une première mondiale la
réintroduction d'oursin en mer
Méditerranée dans tout ce sont 100 000
jeunes oursins qui ont été placés dans
leur milieu naturel un projet
universitaire pour lutter contre la
raréfaction de l'espèce explication et
images récoltées par Marc-Antoine
moutieri pour télépaset on est sur une
espèce Lourdin qui a des petites
difficultés qui semblent fragiliser dans
certaines zones bien sûr et du coup
voilà effectivement on a travaillé
pendant pendant 10 ans sur la
reproduction de l'espèce d'abord puis
sur les modalités éventuellement de
remise à l'eau et aussi évidemment sur
toutes les données écologiques les
données dans le milieu sur les
populations pour pouvoir les remettre
dans les conditions idéales
la protection de la faune marine au
coeur également des préoccupations en
Martinique les eaux de Lille et plus
généralement celles des Antilles
françaises abritent depuis 2010 le
sanctuaire AGOA près 250 000 km² d'air
marine protégées pour les mammifères
marins parmi eux les baleines abos ont
fait leur retour sur les côtes
martiniquaises l'occasion vous allez le
voir pour les scientifiques d'analyser
leur comportement un sujet de Maxime Le
que pour via atv
au large de la Martinique les eaux
chaudes des Caraïbes accueillent de
mystérieuses créatures
comme chaque année les baleines à bosse
sont de retour avec dans leur sillage
des scientifiques
[Musique]
mais avant d'en arriver là il a fallu
des heures d'écoute attentive de la vie
sous-marine grâce à cette hydrophophone
tractée par le bateau dans ce tube on a
plusieurs micros donc on les voit ici
c'est des petites cellules qui sont
présentes et le fait d'avoir plusieurs
micros en série nous permet justement
d'avoir la direction des cétacés quand
l'étudie Jean on va le mettre derrière
le bateau et maintenant on a l'ensemble
du cap on entend une baleine à bosse
donc là on sait qu'on s'approche d'une
baleine à bosse qui est en train de
chanter un mâle
[Musique]
sur les 33 qui sont présentes dans la
carrée donc plus d'un tiers de la
diversité qu'on peut retrouver et parmi
les espèces qu'on a trouvé on a eu des
espèces assez rares comme des sténos ces
offres un peu spéciaux des baleines à
bec on avait une baleine à bec avec un
bébé c'est exceptionnel c'est la
première fois qu'on le voyait
afin de laisser à ces espèces un nouveau
souffle de tranquillité des zones dites
de quiétude devrait bientôt voir le jour
dans le sanctuaire
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci d'avoir suivi ce grand JT des
territoires on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]